citizens of the reject nation if you can
look behind us john tell them where we're at
we're at the prey premiere
the fifth predator movie
and easily the best one since the original and
uh you know what's funny about this premiere
today a movie got cancelled what movie was that
batgirl but what's still coming out that hasn't
been canceled because it's that good pray there
we go we've successfully promoted this movie we
don't know who we're gonna get we're at the end
of the line which means we're their favorite
they're saving the best for last that's what it
means at these uh press junkets that they they
specifically want us to be best for last right
everyone to warm up you know by the time they get
to us then they're ready to really rap you know
that's why they put like variety and hollywood
reporter over there because they're like just uh
screw them let them walk past them they're gonna
run past the variety to get to the real rejects
today hold on i gotta talk to greg and john
we got andrew gordon here to do backup audio which
will not sound as good as this but andrew say hi
what's up citizens of reject nation we don't
know who we're gonna get i just hope that we at
least get a background player press junkets are
like a box of chocolates man it's gonna be good
oh really oh that means the world man you always
do red carpets no are you la local la local yeah
yeah yeah we're getting asked questions my
dad tracked the burrito it's john right there
so sad dude yeah guys we're here with dan
trachtenberg the amazing director of prey a movie
that you guys have told you guys time and time
again love the hell out of it and i know we talked
for a while on zoom um but there was one thing i
did really want to ask you but we ran out of time
which was the predator franchises of course
had some interesting journeys along the way
and now beyond easter eggs was there anything
in particular that you took inspiration from
in the sequels or things you wanted to make
sure you to intentionally like not go into the
pitfalls of oh good question um you know we have
this this net ball situation our movie and that
that is you know born out of uh you know
a weapon that we've seen in in the sequels
so certainly there's that predator 2 has one of
the greatest movie transitions of all time when
you see the guy screaming and then you see that
it's just in his in the predator's hand walking
away and i almost put that in this just one of
my favorite things ever really you know i was
looking at some of the errors that the movies
in my opinion have made in terms of the creature
design and the way it moves and really hoping
that we could pull off what was hinted at in the
first movie the way it jumps through trees and
all that stuff making ours feel as ferocious as
as possibly could do you have an extended cut of
this film because i love the length it's tight but
was there ever an extended version of this
the weirdest thing in the world this movie
really wanted to be 90 some minutes it the
first cut the editor put together was about
90 minutes the first cut i put together
and showed the studio was about 90 minutes
it's weird i think that's because it's so so much
of it is his action sequence it ended up that way
but yeah it's i'm proud of it being a brisk film
yeah it's kind of got that mad max telling story
through action kind of flare to it you know do you
mind if he gets one question in with you while we
got some time yeah i'll keep it at one i've got
a bunch of curiosities but one thing i really
appreciated and sort of started to pick up more
and more watching the movie was just how much you
embraced the title themes of prey and predator
and all this sort of overlapping circles that
put animals characters etc in those different
roles how intentional was that were you going for
that or did that just kind of happen as you you
know found the story funny enough heard the last
question the script we even pre-vised used to open
the movies to open on a fly gets eaten by a fish
the fish gets eaten by the hawk the hawk gets
shot down by human like it used to always open
with that sort of hierarchy of the food chain
um because the predator is coming to a planet
looking for what the alpha is and and you know
our our protagonist is trying to prove herself
to be worthy so i just really always wanted
a movie to dig into the thematic weight that
that creature um doing a predator movie has
you know yeah i think you did a great job with
that really quick just one other thing this is
obviously like a big roughing it experience for
your cast how much in the thick of that were you
like did you jump in the mud with everybody or
were you kind of you know removed for rehearsals
and stuff like that no i didn't jump in the money
short answer no it's good good i appreciate
that thank you fruits i appreciate it
hi everybody we talked on zoom for like a few
minutes nice to meet you personally watched all
your interviews but i watched like you're you're
like compilation are you watching it yeah i'm so
curious about what other people said so i was like
oh how did you energy very well done oh thank you
so much we already absolutely love it thank you
for taking the time to come back also through
the slime it means a lot but since i already asked
you a couple questions but there's a couple that
i didn't get to ask you i'm excited let's do
let's do it let's do it um one thing was that
especially when talking with a lot of people here
coming to the carpet earlier they were talking so
much about their experience working with jane
about capturing a lot more of the sincerity and
authenticity through the comanche nation what
would you say was some of the things that you
learned the most about the comanche nation that
you got to apply into this film or takeaway that
you want the audiences to actually have there
were so many things i mean you know learning i
think it was mostly like the differences between
comanche culture and like my culture i come from
lakota dakota and dakota people i'm enrolled
at the four pack reservation in montana so
you know that's also plains people but obviously
we're not all the same uh different language
different culture different practices stuff like
that so like learning the things that we shared
and then the things that were different like for
example in the movie they're hunting a hawk and
i was like oh my god what do you what because
we never do that but she was like no no or or
you know we share things like there's a whistle at
night in the movie and you know that's like a big
thing for both of our cultures so getting to not
just like learn about it and have conversations
and i mean even like on set jane was like
making outfits for like her grandkids and like
you know she made like earrings that i've
worn during press so far like that's great
that yeah like that kind of stuff it was just
also like learning things like that that's just
like personal to my life that are like good to
know or good to see or you know brush up on some
skills like that kind of stuff was just like to me
personally such a gift and then yeah like getting
to put things in the movie or like brushing our
teeth like dan at one point was like did people
brush their teeth down and we're like of course we
brushed our teeth what are you talking about and
like she literally like brought out a knife and
like made a toothbrush and she was like stay here
and then that's in the movie and you
know it's not like here everybody i'm
brushing my teeth but it's just a part of
the movie so like that kind of stuff is like
to me so cool oh that is awesome um my buddy
loved the movie too he's worse than telling
me is there any chance of controlling you
just get one question in with him too yeah
absolutely come on in here john come here awesome
it's lovely to meet you hello nice to meet you
it's great too because when i watched
the movie i literally shouted chew stick
um but i'm curious i mean you know so much of
this obviously is very cultural and whatnot
but it's also very physical and i know that you
had to do a bunch of like badass fight training
but also too you're just like roughing it out
in the land for so much of the movie is that
kind of akin to how you are in general
was it kind of a challenge being
so just outside the whole time and so
kind of immersed in all of the elements
i enjoyed it i grew up like i brought my dad a set
of throwing axes for father's day like a couple
years before this movie i think or like my i don't
know when sometime before this movie existed in my
life and then this movie happened and i
was like oh my god i've been practicing
it paid off yeah so like you know not for nothing
so definitely that kind of stuff like i just grew
up like my parents had a few acres of property
and we had like dirt bikes and dogs and horses
and things like that so like it definitely
felt nice to me to like be shooting a movie
and then i would just so often forget because you
know like then being outside and interacting with
like the environment and the elements just becomes
like the thing you pay more attention to and then
you're like oh right well that's how the movie
guides your attention too like every time you fade
back into just being in the camp you completely
forget about predator stuff in the first place
that was how it felt shooting the movie i feel
like we shot like three different movies there
was like a comanche camp movie there was like a
naru solo journey movie and then there was like
a predator movie and i was like oh my god this is
better movie well awesome thank you so much really
appreciate it dude what's up pleasure pleasure to
meet you in person man i did not realize how just
[__] tall you are yeah yeah guys we're with
dakota the most badass people ever right here
thank you so much uh last time we were talking we
were talking a lot about your musical influences
and one thing i was curious about when you
were making this movie do you listen to a
lot of certain songs to get kind of in the mood to
prepare for certain scenes or anything like that
if so like what songs were they 100 you know
there's some certain scenes in the uh in the movie
without going into too many spoilers in which
topic kind of expresses some deep emotions uh
you know and so uh there were certainly songs that
i blasted in my ears i remember one in particular
this was a song that it kind of heard at a weird
time in my life so it kind of always emotionally
brought me back to a certain place but before this
one particular scene i just put the headphones in
i cranked viva la vida by uh was it cold play
yeah yeah is that what it's called i know what
time you're talking about yeah yeah yeah sorry
to get remember but that that song really uh did
a lot for me along with many other songs but yeah
certainly played a part in would you say that your
character has a pers if your character had a theme
song what would you say that theme song would be
oh man that's a good question only daddy that'll
walk the line by wayland jennings for sure
that's a great answer this is my buddy you talking
recognizing to the chair reaction i was wondering
yeah yeah what's up i was wondering could he
ask you a question he's a big fan of the movie
too we absolutely love this man john why don't
you come in here thank you dakota appreciate
your time man thank you thank you yeah it's lovely
lovely to meet you seriously i watched the movie
last night and i was blown away and i gotta ask
i mean you know are you an outdoor kind of person
or was this like a really big sort of you know
foray into just roughing it and how much did you
kind of have to practice at you know the like
watching you guys build that that um the gurney
in that one scene was like so clockwork and
things like that so like what was the process like
for the physical preparation you know i i loved
uh when i still love i loved going out in the
woods as a kid you know so luckily that aspect of
it was kind of enjoyable for me i really enjoyed
being able to go out like on an off day and
just i'm gonna go sit in the field on six ago
you know that's uh that's a res up there just to
kind of you know decompress so i love that part
of it you know i think if i was on a studio lot
or something i would kind of go a little crazy
maybe for that being my first movie it was a lot
of a lot of preparation a lot of work you know
there was a diet that they put me on to kind of
make sure i look skinny and sinewy you got the
hollywood abs you know yeah yeah so that was
that was like a little bit of that but man the
exercise i don't mind so much you know so it was
fun but uh different experience for me for sure
for sure was there a particular skill that you had
to pick up that you're gonna take with you beyond
this experience oh man so one thing that i really
enjoyed uh was shooting the bow from the horse uh
man oh cool dude i spent a lot of time riding uh
and when we were practicing i would actually shoot
the bow from the horse and that's it's kind of a
wicked experience whenever we're with all the crew
i'm not allowed to shoot real arrows so the kind
of cgi those in uh which was disappointing for me
but you still want to hit the target oh thank you
bro i hope so it was fun very appreciate it hey
thank you guys thank you for your time it's been
more than a pleasure thank you i love watching
your videos appreciate that thank you so much we
talked uh briefly uh on the on the zoom interview
during the press junket so it's nice to see you in
person i'm not a little square much more lovely in
person one thing that i did want to ask you that
i didn't get a chance to on the zoom park one part
of this film that i was thinking of when watching
it was a part of the storytelling feels like
because i don't know much about the comanche
nation but it feels like if the predator was
plopped down into the comanche nation during this
time here's how they would respond how much was
the thought process put into that to provide the
authenticity and do you feel like this was like
the most authentic representation they would do
for this type of larger-than-life sci-fi story
oh absolutely because for the comanche nation we
have a mythology and in our mythology there's a
monster called pia muppets and translated from
our language that means big monster and when
it's described it's almost like the predator this
tall big alien monster with small eyes big arms
nails grabs you know is out at night so it fits
perfectly we just screened it for the comanche
nation and everybody was thrilled to see to see
that and they were like see the predator could be
that pia muppets and now everybody will be scaring
their kids because the kids will be like you know
you better behave or else p.m muppets is going to
come and get you and now it's a predator you know
can i ask what was the what was your emotional
reaction to screaming for the imagination what was
your emotional response to seeing that it was very
emotional for me i'm an enrolled member of the
comanche nation i'm also black feet so just this
is the first time that our language has ever been
in in a new movie ever an entirety you know
like through the whole movie we have the
whole thing dubbed in comanche which was an
undertaking and then we here let me just say
but also you know just for native people when this
comes out the world can click that tile and watch
it in the comanche language so this is the first
time that any native language has been out in a
brand new movie ever so how would you say that
being here tonight celebrating this movie here
is making you feel just to know that all this
is being celebrated and like the the early word
of mouth is so enormously positive yeah it's like
a it's like a landslide every time i go somewhere
and they're like did you work on prey and you
know what was that like oh it's a predator we
love the predator because he has such a great
fan base so it's a really great platform to
show native people as real people to not show
us as a sidekick to not show us as a villain
but to show us as a viable real people that have
they love each other these brother and sister
they have conflict like everybody else you know
brothers and sisters because i know i did and uh
i'm sure most people do so you know it
just shows us more in a real way of life
well you you actually answered my follow-up
questions so thank you my father no my my
follow-up question was basically going to be about
what would you hope that people would take away
from this movie because i imagine that with the
movie like prey you're like oh comanche nation
exploitation b-movie but then it's actually not
that it's actually so much more than that and what
are you hoping people would take away and you just
did that you answered that for me you say yeah
you're psychic you're very skilled you have to
thank you so much for your time jane thank you
great cameo too i call you last night and i caught
you over amber i want to do that to leave a little
trail for my uh for my grandchildren you know so
they can go god that was our grandma and look well
actually i was riding a horse in the beginning
when you see the two people when nadu's walking
up the thing going to the camp there's two people
on horseback i i'm on the left riding the horse
i'm everywhere i'm everywhere it's like we were
we were in canada and the borders were closed
i'm everywhere thank you jay stormy pleasure to
meet man thank you man sonic nice to meet you nice
to meet you thank you my name is greg we saw this
movie and no [__] [__] love the hell out of it
it was like insanely amazing like we're big fans
of the predator franchise and this is easily like
the best maybe the best one since the original
so yeah but so i gotta ask when watching this
the camaraderie between the entire cast felt so
sincere and so authentic what went into building
that camaraderie leading into the filmmaking oh
brother man i got some stories for you yeah let's
hear it let's hear it kevin starr blanket homeboy
stunt coordinator ending guy right okay he's cree
badass dude man teaching us how to maneuver
tomahawk fighting knife fighting working
with bows we had a four week boot camp that's
the only thing we [__] did all right we're
getting deadly we're maneuvering we're working
in diamond formation we're learning how to peel
off left and right without even saying a
word we got hand signals we're like stop
bro yeah we're moving and and the sign language
we're using is we're trying to connect it to
actual indian sign language that the comanches
used so we're trying to use a jane of course
jaymar did it she showed us and she i'm glad
we had it i think the thing what made this
film so successful was the fact that we had jane
a native woman who is that tribe who had knowledge
of that who made sure that this film
was able to go far because otherwise
if they did like a pan-indianism right they would
have mixed up concepts of what tribes were and
that wouldn't have made it as good but the fact
that think about this man all right one of the
scenes opening credits on the trailer too you see
um harlan he has his arrow pulled back like this
hand over the top there's a reason for that all
right it's because when you're riding horseback
and if you knock it on the bottom the arrow fall
out so you knock it on the top you're moving
maneuvering the boys arrows already in keep on
rolling all right and then we're working on like
holding multiple arrows in our hands at once and
firing i kid you not kevin taught us how to curve
a [__] arrow bro curve and arrow damn so it's
all real yeah yeah and we're doing the lid that's
what made it so real because we're actually doing
the stuff so when it came time to film we already
knew how to spread out roll and maneuver man
so you like the way how this story the story
is kind of told that the action you guys kind
of bonded through learning the action together
yeah yeah and also man we're actually indians
too yeah yeah they didn't do like a spaghetti
western like they used to do we're actually
indians and it's in our bones it's genetic
so would you say a lot of these skills were
they more fine-tuned or did you actually learn
did you know a lot of this before you actually did
the movie both my man both like growing up on the
res i already knew how to hunt how to maneuver how
to be quiet how to sneak up on something working
with the bow something my dad shot me a little
bit kevin starr blanken refined it made it sharp
tomahawk fighting i actually didn't know i've
never talked about it before man you know
but now i'm you know i'm pretty
i'm pretty pretty wicked with it
even with the blade we're working some blade
stuff i had this old back in uh i was 12 years
old jim harrison karate veteran right yeah went
to cambodia old war veteran badass dude right
worked with chuck norris a little bit back in
the days yeah he's like he's legit taught me
had a knife fight when i was a kid nice nice
yeah so and then i was like i already know i
kind of have an idea i got some good ideas how
to do this i just rolled on over easy to films
so that's why i have a double tomahawk man
yeah yeah both hands are deadly with both hands
thank you dude you were [__] badass did you
like that when i jumped up on that log bro
yeah the log was literally this high it
was like it's not this high that long
was this it looked dangerous as [__] yeah yeah
it was literally this higher and i was standing
there and i was like oh man i got a box jump
this cuz i got to make these guys look badass and
they're like just maybe crawl over it and i was
like listen listen listen alright you can maybe
crawl over and i was like listen guys let me show
you some true athleticism right now what i can do
as an actor just beyond acting some some real
warrior [__] that log was literally this big
[__] shoulder length and the film it looks
smaller but in reality it was literally i put
my hole it was a standing box jump cleared
it and i was like man i only got about 10
good jumps in me after this man and that's the
one where i jump up on the log and i walk over
there's and i'm like yeah man so you know just
yeah that's what i did man i tried my best it was
a pleasure talking to you dude thank you so much
thank you so much man hey you definitely have a
good day now all right take care man thank you
thank you for coming back we we saw this movie
and um the only way i can communicate this is
by just having a little bit of swearing here
i [__] love the hell out of this movie it is so
amazing it is so amazing so many of your scenes
with amber have so much of this like unspoken
dialogue in history what was the relationship
building like with you and amber with developing
these characters there's so much history without
you guys having to even really talk about it
yeah you know amber and me immediately clicked
okay um sorry i've got something in my eyes so
just know that i need to cover it because my
eyelash it was watering so bad thank you thank you
thank you he's my he's my cleanest handler amber
and me immediately hit it off we didn't really
even need the time to sit and say okay who are
you and me and how's our relationship it was like
i just think you're an amazing human being and
she's so genuine and we just floated into it
it was really natural between us so you guys
were able to just sort of feel it out like it
was real acting right yeah i mean i immediately
adored her and loved her as a mother would
and we had a we just had some really beautiful
conversations between takes and you know when
we were just hanging out on set and in calgary
because we shot this in canada and yeah yeah
so i think with indigenous people we recognize
each other and we just know that you know it's
okay we don't have to talk too much with this
character there was so much of this history hinted
at with the with the father actually uh being gone
was there any of that backstory that you
would like to have seen be explored a little
bit more that perhaps you did some of your
own homework on prior to making this movie
um i think for me i knew the father was gone
but all i thought of is i'm playing father and
mother to my kids and i really have to be able to
set them on the right path my son obviously would
be you know bringing in a lot of how we survive
you know a lot of the animals a lot of the the
food i just wanted my daughter to do what i did
which is you know take care of the female stuff
and she just refused to listen no matter what i
mean i tried so hard to make her be a normal woman
and she just wouldn't she refused and she became a
hero and she just kicked ass i mean you guys have
wonderful screen presence together my buddy here
he absolutely love it can he ask you a question
too is that fine all right thank you thank you so
much for your time you did a really terrific job
in the movie i feel like it can often be sort of
a role to get stuck with playing mom and whatever
but i thought you really came to life and i was
curious you know i mean obviously this talking to
everybody tonight it seems like this means a lot
to people and there is a lot of culture alive in
the movie was there anything you had to prepare
for or was it mostly things that you already kind
of brought in from your own personal experience
well i think i am a mother of two daughters and
i think it was just a very natural relationship
with my my kids on the film with dakota and amber
and we we just we just rolled with it we
didn't prepare with each other we didn't
we didn't even run lines really we just kind of
showed up on set and just trusted each other and
knew that it would be there we all know ourselves
as indigenous people so and did you have any like
trepidation i mean like predator movies or
exploitation movies in part and i think it
would be really easy to just lay a skin over it
being like oh look we said it you know in in the
comanche nation ha ha but it really feels like is
an authenticity to that and i was curious you know
having it pitched to you and finally signing
on you know like how did that read on the page
i was really happy to have an indigenous
producer on set i thought that really made
a big difference because everything felt
really authentic having jane myers there
who was comanche so she was able to speak into
things and i thought that was really important
it's not often that we get to show such strength
in who we are as a people i'm not comanche i'm
cree but i mean as indigenous people we were
often portrayed as you know savages or you know
stereotypes and for me this felt really authentic
it reads that way yeah do you have a favorite uh
i'm gonna crib one of your questions do you have
a favorite of the predator franchise aside from
this one are you an action horror monster fan i
am not an action horror and i've never watched
the predator i didn't even watch it to gear
up for the film it's more authentic that way
yeah yeah no i'm more into drama like just
acting and good you know writing and stuff
and i'm not an action person there's so many
action films i have not watched so that's good
that i feel like part of the benefit of this movie
is that that authenticity really reads like when
you dip away from predator things and just go
into the life in the camp it's like you really
get pulled into all that stuff so i thought you
guys did a terrific job just realizing all of that
i did not want to watch it specifically because
i didn't want to lean towards anything from
any of the past predators so i just thought i
haven't seen it yet i'm not going to watch it
i'm just going to save it so it's perfect what
was it what was it like to skin that giant hide
well i've done that a few times this is just a
regular day for you in my backyard i skin hide
well awesome appreciate your time
thank you for talking with us